(gentle music)
- It would be I love you.
I would be don't be sad because I'm gone.
I'm always here
and it's gonna be okay,
it's gonna hurt for a really long time,
but I'm always a part of you.
Because my brother passed away
and that's what I would
wanna heard from him was
that he loved me and I
know it's gonna be okay.
And I was gonna miss him
for a really long time
but then he's always a part of me
and will always be a part of me.
And I wish I could have
I love you one more time.
(gentle music)
- Oh man.
What is it, great question.
It would probably be pray for someone
that they got the thing that I wanted.
I think that was the kind of
thing I ever did for them.
So I was trying to give it
up you know from my heart.
(gentle music)
- I don't know.
I've actually been struggling
a bit with this lately
cause like I don't necessarily see it
when I look in the
mirror, but I see it a lot
when I look at like other imperfect things
like we were just at the zoo
and I love the orangutans
and other people will come and be
like oh, he's chunky, look how fat he is.
And I just like think he's so beautiful,
the male orangutan and
so great I'm gonna cry.
So it's I don't know I think...
- [Female] Do you want me to stop?
- No, it's okay.
None of this is gonna be usable.
Um no so I don't know,
I think it's like in the
imperfections like no one looks
at like a Lego brick and thinks, oh man,
this Lego brick is beautiful
cause there's 10 million of 'em,
but it's yeah, I guess though,
it's just like being able
to see the imperfections the right way.
We'll go with that (laughs).
(gentle music)
- My mom passing away from breast cancer.
(laughs) Sorry.
- [Female] It's okay,
do you want me stop?.
- No it's okay.
Just learning to accept it, talk about it.
It's been a long time,
it's been 14 years now.
It's still you know, but
just learning to remember her
and think about her but remembering
what she wanted for me
and trying to look that.
- [Female] So you feel
like you're living a life
that she would want?
- Yeah because I was always
a very like conservative,
you know straight edge and my
mom was very like, you know,
she just didn't care what people thought,
she didn't feel like she had to live
within certain expectations.
She just a free spirit, that's
the word I'm looking for.
Whereas I was very like by the book
and so I try to live more free-spirited.
(gentle music)
- Okay I'm ready.
I'm ready to talk about it.
So it was about 14 years ago,
the name of the dog is still
my password for everything.
So this was very deeply emotional for me.
It was late night, it was my
sister's birthday actually.
I think it was her 15th birthday
and all the adults were having a good time
and they left the side gate open
so the dog had run away from the party.
It was too much noise.
It was my first pet.
I grew up with this dog, I raised this dog
and it ran all the way
up to the side street.
It's kind of a busy street
I guess and people drive up
and down trunk hauling pretty frequently
and we heard a loud screeching
sound like tires I guess
so we went up to the road
just to check it out.
We thought there was maybe
a car accident or something.
Notice the dog was missing
and everyone started panicking
and they didn't want me to
go cause I was too little
at the time but I scooted
all the way out there,
it was like half a mile away
and I saw my dog was still
alive on the side of the road,
a black lab, beautiful
and she was only a shoot
like eight years old, I guess.
So she's getting up there
but too young for a time
and you know, I ran up to
her and I held onto her
and I just bawling my eyes out of course,
I was a little one,
but she died right there with
me on the side of the road.
And we had a little
funeral for her that night,
dug a little hole.
Everyone helped kind of dig
one shovelful at a time.
But you know, it taught me about loss.
Until then, I had no one in my life die,
no family members or anything
and it was kind of the closest thing
that I felt to losing
something important in my life
and I still think about her
almost every day to this day.
(gentle music)
- This lady standing beside me married me.
It was the kindest thing
anybody ever did for me.
(gentle music)
- Not anymore but in the
past I used to be scared
to share my sexuality with people.
- [Female] When did you get over that?
- You know actually it takes
a long time to get over it.
Amongst close friends,
I'd say I was about 19,
but with my family it was
until I was about 22, 23
and then with everybody
not caring anymore,
it wasn't until I was 32.
Yeah I'm 40 now
so it shows you I've only
been free for a short while.
- [Female] What do you
think you were scared of?
- For me, it had a lot to
do with being prejudged
or the being presumed to be a certain way.
I wanted people to know me first
before they interpreted my sexuality
so I was scared of rejection
I think if you look
at the whole rejection I think was it.
(gentle music)
- Yeah.
- [Female] Do you mind sharing?
- Yeah one day I was playing
a game with my grandma
and she got, I knew she
cheated and I got mad at her
and I called her crazy old lady
and she got really mad at me
and threw the cards in my face
and said like who you
think you talking to,
don't talk to me like that again.
And I was just really mad at her,
the next time I saw her
I just was so mad at her
so I didn't really like say
hi, I didn't even hug her.
And that was the last
time I saw my grandma
so I wish I wouldn't have said that.
I wish I would have said I love her.
The last memory I have of
her is me being mad at her.
(gentle music)
- When I was born, my
parents were never together.
They just kind of like a mistake thing
that happened at like some party.
No one wanted me as a kid
so I just got passed around
from family to family.
Just moving schools, never
had the same friends,
never stay in the same area.
It kind of me up but like
it made me who I am today,
got me to where I am.
I liked Bill Bridges
back then and everything.
So my mom was a drug addict
went through a bunch of stuff.
My dad was just busy doing his own thing
so I really didn't have a
consistent family or friends
and then I turned 17, I just
gotta join the military,
go to Illinois and now
it's all in the past
but it was probably the hardest thing.
(gentle music)
- [Female] I either have a 100 subscribers
or a million subscribers
but I'm giving you the stage
to talk about whatever you want.
- Anything?
- [Female] Anything.
- Huh okay.
Dang.
Let's talk about suicide.
I know it's a (mumbles) to talk about
but I lost my brother to suicide in 2010
and I just recently
been more open about it.
And I feel like there's
a lot of light to be shed
on suicide prevention
and signs of depression
and accepting those that have depression
or that are in a dark place.
I'd like to hopefully shed
light someday on that topic.
I just feel like it's
not talked about enough.
It's like a subject that people are afraid
to talk about either because
they're depressed themselves
or they're embarrassed that
a loved one took their life
or maybe they don't understand.
I know I've heard a lot
of times people say,
do you think your brother was selfish?
There was a time where I did but you know,
it's not a selfish thing to do.
I don't think necessarily.
That's the whole thing,
we don't know exactly.
That's why the light needs to be shed.
It'd be good to I think little communities
within our community to
get together and you know,
if you're struggling with
depression just talk about it.
Like we need more peer to peer support
in our communities I feel like
cause there's a lot of
lonely people out there.
When you're lonely, you don't have an out.
Not that my brother was lonely,
it was a different situation
but yeah I guess that's why my topic.
(gentle music)